okay so in this video I'm gonna try to
compare and contrast mitosis to meiosis
now on the Left we're gonna have a
diploid cell with 46 pieces of DNA
that's gonna go through mitosis to make
two cells with 46 pieces of DNA the
cells start and end diploid on the right
this cell will start with 46 pieces of
DNA diploid and it'll go through meiosis
to make two cells but then there's a
second round of meiosis this two cells
divide again to make four cells and each
of them have now half the amount of DNA
so I want to show in the animation that
follows this process a little more
visually let's get started so on the
Left we're gonna have a cell that will
undergo mitosis and on the right a cell
will undergo meiosis and so before we
get started I just want to make a count
there are four strands of DNA called
chromatin loose linear strands of DNA in
this animated cell on the left and then
the animated sound on the right as well
is gonna have four strands of DNA or
chromatin to start so I want to make a
note of it and now we're going to
compare that until at the end and this
key right here is gonna help us
visualize where the DNA came from where
the chromosomes and chromatin came from
the red strands are our DNA that were
inherited from the maternal side of the
family from your mother and the black
strands our DNA and chromosomes
inherited from the paternal or the
father's side of the family so here we
have the cell on the left is an
interphase the S stage of interphase now
this is prior to mitosis and what
happens here is chromatin is duplicated
so the four strands have duplicated of
den of chromatin were duplicated to
become eight and on the right the same
thing the chromatin is duplicated so so
far the cells really you can't tell any
difference between the two processes now
as we move on into prophase of mitosis
on the left the nucleus will dissolve
well in prophase number one of
meiosis on the right the same thing the
nucleus dissolves so far there's really
no distinction between the two and now
as we move on into prophase of mitosis
on the Left we're gonna see the loose
linear versions of DNA called chromatin
coil into these X shaped structures
called chromosomes and on the right hand
side the same thing the chromatin coils
into chromosomes now I've numbered the
chromosomes notice how there are two
chromosome number ones one in red that
you inherited from your mother and one
in black that you inherited from your
father same thing there's two chromosome
number twos now in humans there's 46
chromosomes so this two chromosome
twelve and two chromosome 21s and two
chromosome 19's so for simplicity I just
drew a cell with four total chromosomes
and so as we go on into prophase one of
meiosis what happens next is synapses
and what this is is where the two
chromosome number ones are pulled next
to one another by spindle fibers and to
chromosome number twos have pulled next
to one another
this creates groupings called tetrads
notice how the tetrads
are made from two chromosome number ones
or two chromosome number twos you will
not see a chromosome number one paired
with a chromosome number two you you
would not see a chromosome number 13
paired with a chromosome 19 tetrads are
created from the homologous chromosomes
and we have two chromosome 12s and two
chromosome 19's and two chromosome twos
so these are what the tetrads are so why
does synapses happen synapses sets up
what's called crossing over the
recombining of the homologous
chromosomes and what happens is that
chromosome portions of chromosome 2 in
red will actually break off and reattach
with portions of chromosome 2 and black
this recombines portions of our
homologous chromosomes with one another
now the same thing happens in the other
tat red portions of chromosome number
one will break off and reattach with
portions of the other
number one so the tetrads experience
crossing over synapses and crossing over
only happened in prophase one of meiosis
this does not occur in mitosis so now
we're ready to move on into the
metaphase stage on the left metaphase of
mitosis spindle fibers will actually
pull these chromosomes just randomly to
the equator or the middle line of the
cell and on the right hand side spindle
fibers will pull these tetrads randomly
to the equator or to the middle line of
the cell and as we now move into
anaphase of mitosis on the left the
spindle fibers will engage in a
tug-of-war where they pull on the
chromosomes where the actual chromatids
are pulled to opposite ends of the cell
and on the right hand side anaphase one
of meiosis the spindle fibers engage in
a tug-of-war and actually pull apart the
tetrads the tetrads are separated with
one chromosome being pulled to the left
one chromosome of a tetrad being pulled
to the right and so now we move on into
telophase of mitosis on the Left
cytokinesis the cytoplasm begins to
split the cell into halves two cells as
that happens the nucleus begins to
regrow and as that happens the
chromatids begin to unwind back into
their loose linear version of DNA known
as chromatin now on the right hand side
telophase 1 of meiosis cytokinesis again
begins to split the cytoplasm in half to
create two cells and sometimes the
nucleus regrow sometimes it doesn't in
this animation I just had it regrow for
the sake of just showing that sometimes
it will regrow and if we stop and
evaluate the mitosis cell on the left
this is the end of the end result we've
created two diploid cells now we're not
finished with the sow on the right for
meiosis so we're gonna continue that
next so the cell on the right is going
to continue through the second round of
meiosis
now we're in prophase 2 of meiosis now
the nucleus simply read solves now
there's no more synapses there's no more
crossing over so the next round of
meiosis prophase 2 metaphase to anaphase
2 telophase 2 it's very similar to
mitosis in what happens now we're moving
on to the metaphase to again there was
no there there is no second synapses
there is no second crossing over so
we're moving on into metaphase number
two of meiosis and the chromosomes are
simply pulled to the middle line or the
equator of the cell by the spindle
fibers and so what happens next as we
move on into anaphase number two of
meiosis is that the spindle fibers
Tuggle have a tug-of-war and pull on the
chromosomes so hard that the chromatids
are pulled to opposite ends of the cell
and as we move on into telophase number
two of meiosis the cytoplasm begins to
divide in a process known as cytokinesis
but now it's two cells have been divided
into four as that's happening the
chromatids are unwinding back into their
loose linear version of DNA known as
chromatin and as that's happening the
nucleus is reforming in all four of the
cells so notice what you have four cells
created well if we do a little end
result you notice that it's not just
four cells that are created but the four
cells are haploid now let's look at the
cell on the left the cell on the left
the new cells have the same amount of
chromatin as we started with now we put
a note that there were four strands of
DNA to start and notice how there's four
strands of DNA in the two cells created
by mitosis now look to the right and see
my note I noted that there are four
strands of DNA to start but the new
cells only have half the amount they
only have two strands of DNA this is
because of the second round of meiosis
we created haploid cells and in the left
notice the cells created by mitosis are
identical there's two
full strands of black to full strands of
red chromatin but the cells on the right
are genetically unique because of
crossing over and the recombining of
those portions of homologous chromosomes
way back in prophase number one each
cell is genetically unique so as we wrap
this up the cells on the Left created by
mitosis they start diploid and they
ended diploid
but the cells that undergo meiosis on
the right they started half excuse me
they started diploid but they ended
haploid so here's a little practice quiz
you know pause the video and try to
answer these questions and if you're in
my biology class you know bring your
answers on a separate sheet of paper I'd
love to check your answers for accuracy
so I hope you found the video helpful
and comment below please and thanks for
watching